alors vous savez comment ça se déroule
si vous avez déjà vu je comprends bien
les missions vous feignez je vais juré
de prendre celui-là pas ça au hasard en
fait ils écornée voilà bien montrer que
ça dure et est jamais revenu net
proposait un nouveau numéro à la
direction du cabaret du lido
[Applaudissements]
bien amené on
toutes
ces
[Musique]
images
comme riches ça c'est pourri ça c'est
pourri
génial c'est beau mais c'est bien quand
je pense qu'ils ont fusé serbie d'autre
part images d'une manière on n'a rien à
regretter un puisqu'on fait gala du
troisième âge des éboueurs à bas la
monarchie ont
continué 8,3
ktc plus chez moi
tout de suite
récupérons les cerises
bio est
ouverte pour les semaines
[Applaudissements]
les gueux les
abatteuses les vieux slip les tomates
les poireaux
les restes de gâteaux n'y
aa pas l'appétit
télé c'est plus chez moi
je suis français
moi je vais vous dire les fils un numéro
qui va leur parler broker a vu sa valeur
à l'étoile à des factions sont pas à
leur dis toi il faut quand même qu'on
corps on voit la chorégraphie sortie de
poubelles à l'héparine à la taxe à la
tentation
excusez moi si je crois une poubelle de
salle de bain
ce qui fait 3 4 c'est moi bon ben alors
à 2,3 on dit qu'on va trouver le
candidat qui sait les loges c'est vrai
on dit que dans nos vies gars du reun la
beauté du jura c'est vrai quand les 800
pourri non les jeunes quand on viendra
si nous on le jette ton si on dit qu'on
avait tous belle mais c'est pas si mal
non
ouais
n'oubliez pas ce qu'on nous a dit on
nous a bien prévenu à les ivoiriens dans
la moitié qui parlent pas complètement
française alors à se faire celui-ci l'a
mis
là
la
merguez
d'al hannana moi même à la la la la la
la fatma l'aja
la
belle
la mariée plus à l'éboueur
la cité phare et en plus des salaires il
ya des avantages et la récupération
c'est dingue ce que les gens les jettent
dans les poubelles comme ordures ah
ouais avec un cage aux meubles
sur 6,4 bien tu vas avec elle et que
vous versez que par exemple le dimanche
eh ben il t'amène promener dans sa benne
c'est bien il peut t'emmener au bois ou
pour y rester toute la nuit fall a
relaté dans la belle au bois dormant
et puis de travail de matelas tueur et
10,1 il m'a aimé toute la nuit mont nébo
audit anciens rebelles les éboueurs
retraités des poubelles il atteint la
finale et rappelait le cas
d'interruption
wallah crois qu'ils pouvaient les
poubelles car s'ils pouvaient coulaines
par l'arrivée c'est celle qui sent
mauvais et puis comme ça elle s'attend
des pieds fois plus sous les bras mais
pas du tout c'est la poubelle devant
papa poubelles poubelle par ci poubelles
poubelle par la bbc les chants des
danses à ces trucs là
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]